MALE SPEAKER: Is it here yet?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No,
still showing 7.3.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm sure
they haven't forgotten.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: I'll tell
you what, they'd better not
have forgotten.
MALE SPEAKER: That's right.
What about now?
[CHIMES]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes!
Yes!
It's here!
Google Play services
7.5 just got installed.
It's here!
Welcome to Google
Play services 7.5.
This is an epic release
with lots of new features
that allows you to
build better apps.
That's right, because that's
what this is all about.
Enabling you to
build better apps.
We're so excited and there's
so much new stuff in here
that we must get
started right away.
Google Cloud Messaging is
one of the most powerful APIs
in Google Play
services, providing
messaging between your mobile
app and the back end server.
And now we've made
it even better
with support for topic
based subscriptions.
Before topics, all the apps
running all the devices
had to filter out messages
that were not relevant.
Because it was not
possible for the running
app to tell GCM which
messages it was interested in.
Well, with the new topic
based subscriptions
this problem is solved.
Simply define the topic
string that you subscribe to.
For example, topics
hockey, and then GCM
will send messages only
to the devices that
have subscribed to the topic.
This saves bandwidth,
battery resources,
and you write less code.
That's why this is amazing.
And the subscription filters
are really flexible too.
You can use any classification
after the topics keyword
to define your topics.
For example, the latest
episode of my favorite show,
my favorite hockey
team, or my only stock.
In this release we also have
the GCM network manager,
which will schedule your
background tasks whenever
most appropriate for
efficiency and battery savings.
Perfect when syncing data with
servers when new information
becomes available.
Using GCM network manager
you can configure tasks
to run either as one offs,
meaning that they run once,
or periodically.
And in addition
to that, it's also
possible to specify conditions
that must be satisfied
before the task is executed.
For example, the task
probably requires network.
But it goes even beyond that.
You can also require that
the network is unneeded.
For example, a Wi-Fi network.
Or that the device needs
to be charging white
executing the task.
So lots of good
flexibility here.
And that brings us over
to-- yup, that's right,
we got a new API.
Let's welcome the app Invites
API with a round of applause.
How many times per day do you
receive generic information
from big corporations
that want your attention?
Lots of times.
And most of the times
you ignore them.
Just because it's coming from
a big corporation and it's
a generic message.
But what if you instead
receive the recommendation
from a friend?
That's a completely
different situation.
Your friend invested
time and energy
to send you a recommendation.
You'd better look at that.
That's what app
Invites is all about.
And now we're
launching it in beta.
Enabling your users to
invite their friends
to check out your app, like
a friend recommendation.
They just select
the people they want
to invite from their Google
contacts, or use email, or SMS.
And it's even possible to
have a deep link in the invite
so users can get directly to
a particular piece of content
in the app that you
are recommending.
Now over to Cast,
that allows your app
to show things on many
millions of displays.
And in this release
Cast includes a new API
called the Remote Display API.
Wouldn't it be great if
an app on your device
could display content
on the Cast receiver
and at the same time show
other content on your device?
That's exactly what the
Remote Display API enables.
With this API you're app
would have two screens it
can read the content to.
One of the screens is
displayed by the Cast receiver
on the remote display.
And the other is
displayed on your device.
This means you
could for example,
create a game where you see
the action on a big display,
and you use your device as the
remote control for the game.
And hey, now the Maps API
is now natively supported
on Android Wear devices.
It's now possible to present
fully interactive maps
on a wearable device that
includes scrolling and zooming.
You could also show Street View.
This baby uses current position,
uses lites mode maps, and much,
much more.
Another feature in this
release is Smart Lock
for password, which allows
you to be automatically signed
in to a Chrome website or
Android app with your Google
account.
Let's look at an example
of how this can work.
Say you sign into a website and
choose to save the password,
then this password gets
securely saved in the cloud.
At a later time you decide to
start a corresponding Android
app.
The Smart Lock for password API
can then allow a sign in simply
by selecting the
stored credential.
This is possible since
you have previously
decided to store the
password from Chrome.
And the Android device has
your Google account registered.
This is just one use case
for Smart Lock for password,
which has many more features.
So be sure to check out the
details in the reference
sections at the
end of this video.
And rounding this release
off with news in Google Fit
that now support a very large
number of exercise types.
Here they are, all of them.
And the java log will even
include descriptions of how
to physically perform them.
And for each of
these you can record
the number of repetitions, the
resistance, and the resistance
type.
And while I have no idea
what most of these are,
there is one I do recognize.
Bicep curl.
Let's try that out
in the real world.
[HEAVY BREATHING]
[SQUEALING]
That's it for this release video
of Google Play services 7.5.
But be sure to check out
these resources as well.
Now it's your turn to
build those better apps.
So go out there and
create some great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.